Ừ thôi vãi chưởng nãy giờ chưa nghe gì á
thế mà Mấy ông không hề nói gì tôi cả
nếu tôi tự kỳ
Vãi chưởng nãy giờ mấy hôm nay rồi à
ok hơn nói lại vậy
ờ ờ
ở đầu tiên sinh nhật các bạn ạ
tuần Vắng
ở
tuần qua là tôi Thứ 5 này rồi đi à
anh đi quay với với công ty vì có sếp ở
bên ngoài về có vẻ ra sẽ hứa hẹn là năm
tới ở sẽ được sang nước ngoài để mà du
lịch sử gì đấy vì công ty thôi về cơ bản
nó bên nó ngoan Để rất hay và thử và mấy
ngày nghỉ vừa rồi thì nó sinh nhật mẹ
nên là tôi được đi nghỉ mát hiểu mấy ông
để ý thì tôi tôi dậy khá là đều được cầu
là chỉ một vài cho nó phí hữu thì tôi
mới nghỉ zậy sao rồi rõ ra mà dậy theo
kéo là miễn phí kiểu dạng mẹ rồi còn bảo
kiểu xin nghỉ thêm bội nữa đi không sao
các thứ thứ thì về các bạn mình sẽ miễn
phí mà nhưng mà không Tôi là kiểu từ đam
mê ông cái gì đó thì tôi sẽ sẽ cố hiểu
theo cái đam mê đấy Không không phải
không phải vì đam mê gồm miễn phí thì
mình sẽ sự thiếu trách nhiệm cái gì đó
không
Ừ cái này không phải là cái cái Mọi cảm
xúc thoáng qua thích một cái gì đó về
sau mình có thể chán tôi không phải như
thế
thì vừa rồi mấy ông Để ý kỹ ra thôi vừa
rồi có tra xong với ông xem về trộn
chung pic này thì thì cái câu nói mấy tả
chôn ích Nó là là người đàn ông nhiều
dạng mà tập trung này và có miếng mình
này có sự cam kết này Đấy sẽ will Tôi
nhớ không lầm là tùy ý chí tuyệt đối à
để cả thế khi mà một người đàn ông rồi
ảnh chụp thực sự là muốn làm cái gì đó
rồi Nhà kiến định với cái ý định của
mình để làm Thứ do to lớn tiền hình ạ là
nhân vật chính ở đi chém giết tất cả đấy
ạ
Alo hỏi chém giết hiệu quả như bắn súng
đã thử hư đấy
thì bà đây cũng có mồi trong những bộ
phim hiếm hoi mà kiểu Tôi cảm thấy gặp
mấy ông nên xe nó gọi là nhiều phim hành
động mới tôi sẽ không thích ở đó không
thích chia sẻ người khác vì các bạn đi
nó chạy đâm chém nhau được bom tấn nó
không có ý nghĩa gì cả phím web này hay
vấn này tôi nghĩa đó có để làm cái nghĩa
gì đó Thế mình không có thể xem tham
khảo và a với cùng cái kiểu này tôi sẽ
thích cả phim Người Vận Chuyển đã chôn
pic này như vậy giờ transporter mà vẫn
chuyển này và cả tất cả men Đặc Vụ Đặc
vụ Kingsman kiểu thế thì ngoài ngoài
những cái kiểu dạng hành động bình
thường thì ở nó có 21 đi Nó là cái con
người mà hồi trước tôi đã cố hướng đến
trở thành kiểu dạng nó hồi trước khi mà
tôi là dân trí thức đúng không Tôi cũng
nghĩ rằng là phía sau mình nên có một
cái hình tượng một cái gọi là cái dạng
lắm cho là hình mẫu lý tưởng để mà mình
phấn đấu để mà mình kiểu ví dụ là kiểu
mình sẽ có phong cách ở như thế nào mình
có cách nói chuyện kiểu nhà vớ vẩn
chứ không phải ngoài việc để gắn cái nhá
mà để cho hình dung việc là mình về sau
mình muốn thành con người Nga không biết
nếu không xác định được rồi chưa nhưng
hơi bé ngày thu hồi ạ lớp 12 2 lớp 11 gì
đấy cấp 3 tôi đã ngồi xác định về cái
hình tượng về sau tôi muốn trở thành rồi
là một kiểu quý ông lịch lãm mà kiểu
kiểu thế nên là nếu mà Mấy ông ý kỹ là
tôi sẽ có tí ăn mặc dạng mà trí lực và
kiểu dạng cố hiểu rồi freeship tất cả à
là kiểu ăn mặc kiểu hơi bị lịch thiệp
hơi bị kiểu dạ mà
Ê bà quá Làm tí dùng được có đạm đúng
rồi vì nó không hợp cho người Việt đó
lắm nó cả à Thích mặc vest có thứ
Ừ nhưng mà
Ờ Ờ nhưng mà Đấy phong cách mà tôi nghĩa
là quý âm hả hay khi mà tôi xem qua
những bộ phim rồi hết mấy ông thấy nó sẽ
kia họ sẽ kiểu lạnh lùng ngầu rồi các
thứ tán gái được hơn
nhưng mà đương nhiên gái Việt cũng biết
là Cái đây tôi chơi cảm chứng kiểm chứng
được với mỗi lần nó mặc như thế xong cái
việc cần chạy ờ
hình mẫu lý tưởng nó chứ hiểu rằng về
sau mình muốn thành một người hài hước
hay là một người như thế nào nhưng mà
tôi khuyên Từng có một người vài người
hỏi tôi hiểu người ta thấy kiểu đương
nhiên có tôi không tưởng mà mọi người
nói chuyện rất là ngắn nhẽo từng nói rồi
tôi kể chuyện kiểu cách đọc lại coi được
cười ở chẳng ai cười rồi đấy thì tôi đã
cố trở nên có vẻ Bây giờ có người muốn
lắng nghe mình trí nhớ là như thế thì
người ta cũng hỏi tôi làm cách nào thì
tôi chỉ khuyên người ta vào đôi khi
không cần phải biến mình thành một con
người khác hoàn toàn mà Hãy vận dụng thế
mạnh của mình giờ xử Em à một người nói
em không và F không muốn nói nhiều ấy
thì em cũng không cần phải
cố trở thành một người nói nhiều làm gì
cả nếu mà muốn ra sự một cái ta quý mình
bằng cách là mình thay đổi hẳn con người
mình thì ra thế là sai mình lên à Ừ mình
lên cậu ba cái hình mẫu gì đó mà mình
mình nghĩ là mình muốn trở thành và phù
hợp với điều hành dù ở sửa ông không hài
hước thì ông đừng cố tỏ ra mình hài hước
đó đôi khi thành phố duyên đấy này chả
thế
ờ ờ Giả sử ông muốn người khác nhớ đến
mình thôi ở Ngạn Ừ thì ông có nhiều cách
mà
Ừ tôi đã từng có vài Ông
về ông bạn kiểu Thật ra ông ấy chẳng cả
buổi ông ấy nói được Đúng hai ba câu ý
người nào nhớ 23 câu đầy ông đấy còn nói
ra cậu rất là chuẩn Nói tưởng như thế
Nghe câu này có thể câu đùa hoặc là câu
đấy có thể một câu mà kiểu làm tất cả
mọi người Kiểu này nên nhé Xong rồi tát
lần nữa cho nên đã hội nghị đâu nhé mà
lấy nhưng đã phải ông ông
nói nhiều cũng được mà cả Ông nói câu
nào mà tất cả mọi người cùng im lặng
lắng nghe
Ừ cũng được có rất nhiều cách mà các đôi
khi ông không cần phải biến hình à trung
tâm đâu nhiều ông sợ đám đông mà Thì
không cần biết mình nhỏ trung tâm như
thế rất nhiều tình huống mà tôi thì tôi
hướng hướng ngoại nên là tôi mới kiểu
muốn tạo thêm nhiều mối quan hệ và đương
nhiên ở nhược điểm Tôi không nhớ rồi tất
cả mọi người này xong rồi
nhiều bè hơn nhiều bạn này các thứ thứ
Nếu không hoàn toàn trợ cần phải chở hai
con người như thế nhưng mấy ông nên ý
tôi muốn nói là mấy ông nên có hình
tượng rõ ràng Con Thứ tiện nói về việc
là hình tượng kết hợp với quý ông thì
có một sự thật này tôi sẽ chia sẻ mẹo
trong bé ông này có nhiều người đây
Ê mấy ông vẫn đang ngồi xem tôi vào hôm
nay vẫn tính ngày nghỉ mấy ông vẫn đang
ngồi xem tôi sẽ không Mấy ông không Đang
ngồi xem người yêu đâu
à À đi kìa
À mà tôi có mức cách để mà tôi tán được
gái gái thích ngỡ mình tạo một cái ưu
điểm của bản thân mình Đó là tôi rất cẩn
thận
ở đời con người cẩn thận đây Ừ
Ừ thì à
em thấy cái này ở bởi với tôi tình toán
nhưng ở trường hợp tôi hồi trước tôi
từng có cái suy nghĩ rõ là người thông
minh người ta phải ở tính toán tất cả
trưng hơn trường một Tôi thường mặc xấu
Vân tôi thở ra luôn hay là quan nghĩ
trường hợp tốt nhờ tội luôn chuẩn bị cho
tình một số xấu nhất Rất là sao được là
tôi luôn mang bao lô Hả túi xách gì đó
rồi có một đống rồi đấy để tôi chuẩn bị
rất nhiều tình huống
mấy thằng bạn tôi điền hình sẽ rất yên
tâm khi mà gạ tôi đi chơi cùng tôi chuẩn
bị bọn một thứ gia thế cái như thế hoặc
người yêu mà tôi tán bạn nào đó thằng
bạn ấy cũng sẽ được là thích gần đây
nhất Mỹ bạn gái cũng bảo áo kiểu ưu điểm
em em thấy một trong yếu điểm lớn nhất
của anh đó là anh chuẩn bị hết rồi em
chẳng phải lo gì cả hiểu gì hết
À mà cái này khá phù hợp cho dân công
nghệ chung của mình làm bìa dân lập
trình bởi vì mình suy nghĩ là mình phải
suy nghĩ rất là đa chiều như cái xử mình
phải nghĩ tới đảo trường hợp nhị cùng
những trường hợp là khách hàng nào đấy
là tạo nó bớt cái đúng không Nói thế là
ca tôi là con người hãy tạo bất chính
công ty mẹ tôi hơi bị ở
cột hạn một tí tinh hoàng ở hơi
bực đồng một tí nhưng mà tôi vẫn nghĩ là
các trường hợp để mà cẩn thận này ví dụ
về cái vụ cẩn thận rồi nha Tối rồi luôn
có bằng vài câu rồi à
tất cả một hộp dụng cụ cầu
em kéo xong rồi à
Tìm các thứ thừa cái kiểu hộp thì cục bé
ống thể cha ông thể vào mấy cái cửa hàng
độc Giá
450.000 249 nhìn của Nhật đây có cái hộp
đấy
tôi bây giờ cô còn manh luôn mang khẩu
trang này sắp phần tay này xong rồi
có phải bộ túi cơ
mày Dung à cái túi của tôi có nhiều lắm
1 ngày ăn lại khô ướt này có cả túi ni
lông này này có cần thuốc này các thử
thử
em mang đồ để cho bé chỉ một ví dụ điển
hình là việc là tính thôi cẩn thận
ông ông ghi đi à đi một vài điểm nhấn gì
đó
Ừ thì có nghĩa là người khác sẽ nhờ đến
Long những cái trường hợp đấy
ạ
bây giờ hơn tám giờ rồi nhỉ Tôi tâm sự
nốt cái này cái này ngoài rồi tâm sự tôi
buồn Chia sẻ ý tưởng người mấy ông luôn
Vừa rồi tôi đi tắm Lúc mà cảm xúc dâng
trào Tôi đã nhớ ra được cái vụ này mà
tôi lại bật ra được một cái ý là hai này
mày cũng thường nghe xem à người ông có
khiếu ở ngon nha và thận chứa mấy ông
biết rồi đến số tôi nhá Đây cái này cái
này thì mong mấy ông tập trung lắng nghe
này thì
ờ ờ không biết về ông ấy là nhưng tôi là
con người thích nghe nhạc nghe nhạc rất
nhiều và tôi rất vui chia sẻ nhạc cho
người khác cùng nghe thì tôi thường ai
tạo danh sách nhạc để cho mọi người cùng
nghe cùng nhưng mà nó cũng bị nhược điểm
đó là hồi trước thì nhiều người rất
nhiều người xem bằng 13 dinh nè hồi ấy
tôi đã tạo danh sách mở ba Dinh mày ông
thì bây giờ cha vẫn ra nhiều tiền rồi là
gì nhỉ này sẽ ra danh sách album nhạc mà
tôi đã từng tạo rất lâu rồi đấy nhưng mà
Ừ
nhưng mà thực sự mình mấy ông thấy bây
giờ đây không thấy bây giờ dọn ra mà nằm
thì có làm gì có ai dùng nó ra Dinh đâu
kết hợp việc trên này vẫn thiếu khá
nhiều bài đấy chứ này khá thiếu nhiều
bài hát và thực tế là mỗi kênh mạnh mẽ
cái mình gọi trang web nghe nhạc nào đó
thỉnh thoảng thiếu một vài bài hát nhưng
bây giờ Gần đây tôi để ý Có vẻ có một
trang nó sẽ đầy đủ bài hát nhất và nó
không láng mịn quyền về nói cho nhúng nó
trí nhà như Top là bây giờ tôi ý nghĩa
tôi sẽ tạo một cái trang gì đó mà Trang
trung gian để mà tôi sẽ gọi là lên đấy
để để tổng hợp tất cả những bài hát cậu
mình sẽ test những cái link YouTube như
cái trang ah
are you tube
bài hát YouTube sau đó thì vào thời
trang của tôi và cái trang web đấy Xong
rồi kiểu Ấn Lưu lại để tạo ra một cái
danh sách và mình sẽ cái quan trọng với
điểm nhấn ở đây đó là mình sẽ tạo những
cái hát cho những người chơi bài hát đấy
làm sao ví dụ dẫn sử ở bây giờ Tôi có ví
dụ nhé để tôi thử nó nhé
Ờ Ờ Bây giờ giả sử là tomia có
11 bài là vừa nhập biệt này nhưng mà bài
bài à Có threat này Đấy chẳng hạn thế
thôi bye 1.000 bài nhạc Việt dưới nữa
nhưng mà bày bài pop này không phải grab
này chẳng đấy khi thì nếu mà một là tôi
ấn vào cái trang
Ấn vào cái danh sách Nghe nhạc Việt Đấy
thì sẽ có cả hai bài đúng không Nhưng mà
nếu mà tôi muốn học thêm mà giả sử Tôi
muốn nghe nhạc Việt nhưng mà chỉ nhạc
rap của chẳng ạ thì tôi thấy ấn vào cả
hai hát xác kiểu Phi tơi Kiểu cái ông
hình dung không chở lọc đấy đấy thì nó
sẽ ra những cái bài Việt kết hợp với
grab thôi đấy chẳng hạn thế xong rồi Tôi
chỉ nghe những cái bài Việt Glass đây
tôi đã hướng là sẽ làm heo cả trang web
nó kiểu kiểu như thế nó không biết có
cha là như thế chưa
Ê mấy ông chỉ ra ở có khi mà không biết
cái sang kiểu thật chứ anh nghe nhạc
nghe nhạc cùng cơ
Ừ nhưng mà bây giờ thì nhớ có một cái
xanh đấy rồi nhưng mà nó hơi đểu một tí
kiểu mấy ông biết có cái listen Chúc AE
rồi
ừ ừ
Để bảo nghe cái này là
a e spotify
anh không Không phải cái này
anh ngày quá quá Ok rồi cũng có này có
thể xem YouTube rồi cùng nhau lại Vân
này nhớ là tôi không hưởng như thế nữa
mà tôi là tôi sẽ làm trang web về mà
tổng hợp danh sách nhạc của mình theo
kiểu dạng nhúng YouTube về để mà tạo
danh sách nhạc ạ
I gotta find thì ra không hẳn bởi
spotify thì thì mới ông đã bị nhầm trong
việc là mấy ông tôi bảo rồi bây giờ tôi
có nhạc Việt có tôi vẫn sẽ có cả này vì
nó lại cho mày không dễ hình dung nhé
Có ai có nhạc Việt là Việt Vietnamese
này đúng không cho nó sẽ có nói chung Nó
có hotspots à một bài sẽ có hết xác và
Việt Nam ít nữa à
a and grab này một bài sẽ Vietnamese này
à
các kiểu nhà ấy và tốt nha chẳng nhớ là
sử tôi vào danh sách nhạc Việt Nam ít
thì cả hai bài này sẽ cùng được nghe
nhưng mà nếu mà tôi sister thêm mà chửi
Việt Nam Mỹ grab tô thì bài này được vợ
thôi con những cái bài khác khủng kiểu
Peter không đủ không có khác đấy sẽ
không được Nhưng cậu Thế thì nó sẽ nghe
được hơn
ờ ờ không Tôi có kiếm tiền đó thấy chưa
thấy tôi làm của mình còn kiếm tiền nữa
à à
spotify thể thì đúng à thứ nhất hả Bây
giờ nhiều người dùng spotify hơn nhưng
mà không phải đã số kêu việc là spotify
trên này không có đủ bài thứ hai là
không áp dụng được hãy Phi tơ vừa rồi
cho bà nghe rõ rằng không phải spotify
em trường hợp này rồi à
ừ ừ
duyệt Chrome ít nhất là như thế thôi nhỉ
là không cho tự động bật Thực ra vẫn có
cách lách thì phải cái đấy Để xem đã
nhận và nói chung là tôi nghĩ là tôi có
thể mò phải cái vụ api của YouTube Tôi
sẽ thử mò sao
những ai mấy ông hiểu gì tôi ông Nghĩa
tôi có ý tưởng tôi sẽ thử mò làm cái gì
đó thì trưa nay toàn thế
thì bây giờ tôi đã định chuẩn bị có gì
tới sự chuyện hay ai song song một cái
trang gái xinh của tôi trang trại sinh ở
vì cho tôi sẽ bật mí mấy ông sau khi mà
có vẻ khi nó gần gần ra mắt thì tôi sẽ
bật mí thêm nói ông
à à
anh em ở chia tay người yêu 35 vì họ cắm
sừng nhưng em bị lụy không tốt chúng học
tập được à cảm giác sống trong quá khứ
thật ra thì cách duy nhất thì vẫn luôn
là thời gian để sẽ làm cho mình kiểu
chữa lành mọi thứ về sau định sẽ quên
tuổi thường nghĩa Tôi không ngờ quên
được vì sau để đỡ hơn là bị khi mà nhanh
Người ta cưới chồng đã tự nhiên tôi hết
suy nghĩ rằng à con Nếu mấy ông muốn cố
quên nhanh với các bạn mình không phải
rất là bận rộn bận rộn và thay đổi cái
một tí về phong cách sống nhưng nếu mà
ông vẫn còn sống theo con cách cũng mấy
ông đi con đường cũ ăn những món mà từng
ăn thì kiểu gì sẽ nhớ
nếu mấy ông làm được thay đổi thói quen
Sinh hoạt Vân thì ông sẽ gần nhiều đồ
sát thì mà gọi chia tay xong rồi ra đây
rất tốt
cái vụ bản quyền kia thì mình không rõ
nhưng mình nghĩ ngủ về dùng ai fan của
thằng YouTube về sẽ không sao đâu mà
đúng không Không phải nói không cho đúng
rồi
xanh 13 đó chắc chắn là tôi sẽ đúng luôn
Tôi sẽ dùng cái Facebook của Youtube về
thôi
à Còn nếu mà nhúng theo kiểu dạng là 13
thì chuẩn là sao có la làm được đấy
nhưng soudcloud mà như nó không đủ loài
đâu Nói chung YouTube Bây giờ tôi thấy
đủ 3 nhất ở nó thậm chí ở bài Thập
Nghiên bao nhiêu vẫn có đây là tối nghĩa
tôi sẽ dùng iPhone về Nói chung Hòa B ở
cái tôi muốn là mấy mấy ông cái hình
dung à là sửa tôi sẽ nhập một cái á cái
mô phỏng nhé mình sẽ có một cái tan Anh
nhập thai nhi tốt đúng không nó xong rồi
nhập Linh vào lúc nào nhập Linh này Đấy
sau đó thì mình sẽ từ cái link này lên
lấy ngày mình sẽ gọi lên api của Hoàng
là YouTube để mà lấy thông tin của cái
bài cụ thể là nó sẽ xuất ra ảnh này kèm
À tên hay thù chẳng hạn đấy đấy đi miết
gọi thăm nêu ấy thăm này là Thái thù của
cái bài đấy cậu cứ như thế xong rồi mình
kiểu ăn xác nhận sau đó mình sẽ nhập
những cái hát giá của nó nhập a cho vào
nó kiểu dạng như này đấy đấy rồi tất cả
bài hơi bị mất công một tí với giai đoạn
lúc mà nhập bài vậy có rất nhiều bài
thật sự tôi vào tận 1.000 bài ạ Nhìn
Linh ạ ấy gần như thế nhưng mà khi mà
nhập xong rồi thì lúc 7 khi mà
Hi hi cái vỗ vai của mấy ông có file khi
mà người khác ấn ở phố file của mấy ông
tôi đang định làm cái trang này không
phải mình dùng sẽ mọi người có thể vào
dùng nhé Thì khi và ấn vào có file của
mấy ông ấy sẽ do người ta hoàn toàn thể
Peter Peter kiểu dạng là lọc lọc kiểu
dạng mà đọc theo những cái hót xác người
ta bấm vào cái hót rác nào thì dễ hiển
thị ra một danh sách nhạt
hẹn mà ông đã từng nhập Thì Ừ cái hát
giác đấy người ta hoàn toàn thể ấn ấn
kiểu dạng mà listen chẳng hạn họ sapo
nghĩa là kiểu nghe nheo ngẫu nhiên trong
thời gian sách đấy Cường như thế khi mà
ấn như thế xong thì mình sẽ phải
thì mình sẽ phải cậu Bản chất linh này
mình sẽ có được ID của vậy á ID của cái
video ở rồi mình sẽ có thể là tôi không
biết được là mình có thể làm được cái vụ
là từ toàn bộ cái danh sách ID theo toàn
bộ những cái Peter lại có một danh sách
hay đi đúng không anh xe đi à mình sẽ
hiểu gọi lên api thằng YouTube để mà tạo
một cái á
like tạm thời được không Tôi không muốn
tạo hình led
bằng to kem của bia cả một cái
Temple tem tất cả tạm hội một cái lấy
Tạm thời thì mình nghe để danh sách nhạc
với được không
Ừ đúng rồi nó cần nhiều tạo ra một cái
clip trên YouTube rồi chia sẻ playlist
đấy ý
xác là sao cao lao nào áp dụng ngay
nhưng mà tôi không biết thằng soudcloud
như nó không có filter thể ở một đống
cái hát xác đâu
mà tôi bảo sao tào lao không đủ bài nữa
mình không có chuyện chẳng lẽ là kiểu
bắt người dùng nhập
pressplay thủ công phải bài Nếu mà trên
đấy không có biết con bị ăn bản quyền
hay không nữa có dùng lấy từ YouTube là
tôi nghĩa ồn liên quan cả vụ bản quyền
nữa thì chắc à Thôi nhúng thể dùng
iPhone về cho không có bản quyền gì đâu
Chắc là thế còn nếu ăn mòn quên đi Thôi
bỏ chẳng sao rồi mình làm miễn phí mà
không được thì thôi tôi sẽ Nếu mà giả sử
mà không được thì tôi sẽ tự tạo trang cá
nhân của tôi một cái phong cách riêng
của tôi thì và ai vào xem đi xem chứ
không phải đó chia sẻ cùng thay nữa thì
thì Trang không lẽ bằng tiền
Anh hiểu mấy ông mấy ông biết được là
khi vào trang cá nhân của một ai đó thì
sẽ blog của người ta đúng không ạ thì
tôi sẽ là một cái xanh nhạt của riêng
tôi làm gì hết cũng hay mà
anh bởi vì là tôi nảy ra ý tưởng này
ngoài việc là để chia sẻ cho mọi người
nghe cung chính xác là để cho chính kiểu
ví dụ điển hình là mẹ tôi vào gì tôi
rằng ạ
Hôm qua có bảo tôi có danh sách có danh
sách nhạc cụ khá hay của tôi thường anh
nghe nhạc cũ thời tuổi thơ mà Thì lấy
người mấy người lấy và Thường mấy người
trung niên đã kiểu thế cũng cũng muốn là
cậu dạng là anh
nghe lại những cái bà đấy hả mạ chưa
mình tạo ra một cái danh sách nhạc như
thế nhá Tạo một cái danh sách nhà như
thế sau đó tỉa khi mình khi tôi Nhà bạn
chắc là mình sẽ đẩy lên cái alo là kiểu
Peter Cái gì Cái gì đó sau đó thì copy
cái link đấy gửi cho người ta là người
ta có thể nghe được toàn bộ cái đấy ở
trên YouTube đấy megatech ngoài toàn bộ
là xác mình phải tự gắn với Minh sức
mình sẽ gắn với phong cách của mình có
thể tôi để phòng kiểu tiếng Anh nhưng
anh có ông thích để tiếng Việt là nhãn
không để nhà tí không ngờ vẫn là về cơ
bản nó những cái Star tuyển này thôi
chợ tết tiết kiệm mấy ông bột socola lấy
từ YouTube này thì ra vẫn có thể lấy
được pass của nó và mấy ông hề chỉnh sửa
thêm Nhưng mày cái tác của nói tôi không
nghĩ là nó chuẩn lắm đâu
ừ ừ có thể lấy tác mà nó xong ơi nó bực
mình khi mình nhập vào nó sẽ gợi ý ra
cũng được một cái
à à
Ừ Ok Nhưng mày không hình dung lý tưởng
Đấy nghĩa là tôi sẽ à
Ừ tôi đã khi ở nghĩ ra một cái một cái
nhu cầu gì đó là tôi nghĩ nhiều người
cũng cần đấy số tôi sẽ bật ra ý tưởng
mới làm cái cái dự án này thôi nghĩa sẽ
quần chuộc người ông có thể có thể vào
ngồi mò cung cũng hay mà ngờ
anh có nhiều cái Open Nếu mấy ông sẽ
hiểu Quân thuộc là gì Nó là kiểu dạng
công khai mã nguồn để mấy ông có thể vào
Đóng góp mà mày không thể có thể có cái
đấy về để mà để mà làm cái riêng cho
mình nhưng mà mày kéo quần xuống đấy
đã miễn phí rồi nè em ấy ông đừng đem về
biến thành cái công cụ kiếm tiền được
Ừ Ok nói cho mày ý tưởng tôi là như thế
Hôm nay bắt đầu bài học nha à
bây giờ Giả sử có một vài cái á một vài
cái tin tuyển dụng mà tôi muốn ghi mà
lại chẳng hạn thế ghim bài tuyển dụng
đấy kiệm nó sẽ luôn ở trên cùng cháu rồi
hồi trước tôi có bảo là thực ra mình nên
để cho nó ngẫu nhiên hoàn toàn cho nó
gọi là công bằng Nếu mà có một vài cái
giật sự là giả sử là kiểu bên FPT họ
liên kết với bên mình họa kiểu sẽ tạo
nhiều cơ hội cho bên mình là cũng giờ
tôi không vẫn không ăn được cái gì từ
bên đấy đâu nhé nghe đang nói hả cậu Tôi
thấy tin tưởng của vai bên là một kim
những cái bài này lên đầu chẳng đại khá
như hết giờ ra mình vẫn nên có tính năng
khi lại đã vỡ bay mình sẽ phải sửa lại
một tí
ờ ờ database lại xem cái tao vậy
a nhớ đây đâu Ở đây
cho bé uống hình Du Ngoạn ngày không
hình dung ý tưởng
Ừ thì mình có thể thêm một ở đây nữa
thôi mà cuộc à ít pin chẳng ạ chuyện nhé
ừ ừ
à mà nó sẽ chưa poland Nó gọi là được
ghim ấy không được ghim lại không nói
kiểu như này Nếu mà được ghi mình nó sẽ
đầu tiên mình sẽ phải lấy tất cả những
cái thằng được ghim đã xong rồi mình sẽ
để nó đầu cái danh sách Tức là sao ạ
nhưng mà Yong nhá là sử Tôi có 10 bài có
bình thường mà ông sẽ ông có phân trang
cái tờ việc của ông vừa vào trang web
thì đôi khi nó sẽ là sự ra 9 bài ạ chính
mày ấy cho cậu ba bài 3 bài một dòng
xong rồi có 3 dòng thì sẽ 9 bài đúng 093
ngẫu nhiên em ạ Nhưng bây giờ sử có 3
bài được chị thì nếu bây giờ có thêm cả
vụ ghi mình giờ sự mình sẽ phải lấy toàn
bộ Bài ghim đã sửa lấy ra sau đó thì
mình mới lấy con con số đấy Xong rồi đấy
9 - con sổ lấy là sử là ba thôi thường
cũng ít bài được ghi lắm Ở nhà sửa 324
Nhìn gì đó anh ạ
3000 tôi một tí
anh không Không cần phải làm mất công
ngay Tôi sẽ chỉ cho mấy ông có truy vấn
em lấy ra được ok ok không không không
cần làm mất công nhé nhớ đến hôm làm từ
tính năng này đã rồi tính ờ
bay vụ này trên nhà nhớ cho làm xong đâu
ở nhà ôm sữa sẽ làm xong đến post đâu
nhỉ Không có bóp rồi
anh có bảo tôi nè
anh ở đây nếu sử của mấy ông đã làm đã
tao bay xong mà có các port rồi như thế
này và như hôm trước cũng chưa Ừ hôm
trước chưa làm ship đôi cho thằng post
ảnh ở ngoài chưa thì mấy ông muốn thêm
cột cho thằng boss thì ở mấy ông một mà
mấy ông sửa trực tiếp trong trình cái
file moderation này đều méo thêm cô cho
nó hay là mấy ông sẽ phải ghi phải
em giả sử ở gái cái này đã chạy trên Nó
chạy rồi đưa áp dụng vào thực tế rồi thì
ông không được phép chạy là Mike Tyson
không không có dốc đi làm lại thì mới
ông sẽ phải là mấy ông sẽ phải cộng thêm
cột bằng bằng cái tạo một cái may ở trần
riêng sau đó thì
mấy ông chạy để mà enter để mà sửa cái
bạn đấy thì cách để sửa sẽ pp thí sinh
này
I my sins Make
My sins enter này tôi hỏi là tên như này
nó dễ enter mình sẽ là hát
ít tên Lực
em có luôn này tu
a boss label à
về cách đặt tên nó sẽ như thế này mày
không nhé thì
buốt tối không còn thêm chữ s nên thành
an đây nó không có chữ f
Không sao Không sao tên file này Thực ra
nó không quan trọng lắm Mình có thể mình
chỉ sửa tục ông đấy thôi nghe được
A và cách để mà tôi
sau khi mà tôi thêm hoặc sửa một cái cột
như thế này tôi như hôm trước tôi từng
nói là tôi sẽ sửa Tôi có cái phím tắt để
làm được đấy thì tôi mệt đối với thằng
nạp pesto mình nó có cái là live ạ
template này thật là tối khuyên mày ông
à tạo ít thôi và mấy ông có thiệt tạm
tắt mấy gái mà ông không dùng đi Tại sao
vì nếu mà Mấy ông tặng ngay nhiều vào
mấy ông thích cái này nhiều quá ấy nó sẽ
hơi bị đô một tí bởi vì IDE status tôm
với các bạn khá nặng nó sẽ hơi bị đơ rồi
Ừ cái học không dùng kéo dạng mấy cái
chỗ không mua dụng ngay mới không thể
thích Nếu tắt điện được
sét mà của trưởng từng làm nó không dùng
nữa này mà tôi sẽ dùng cái ít cô này cái
cú pháp ý con này để mà kiểm tra xem ạ
cột đây đã tồn tại chưa về tôi sẽ thử
làm cho mẹ em nhé còn tạm tắt máy đi
Em in Plus
có vài cái thôi chẳng dùng nhiên sẽ tập
bớt đi trong mấy ông đỡ
ừ ừ
anh sex hot
cho nó đỡ thì đây tôi sẽ sửa lại đây ít
kho Này
Tab và cái đó nó sẽ kiểu dạng ngay Boss
tôi phải ấn excape để nó không nhảy sang
ấy gợi ý cho ta xong nữa này mỗi lần này
á Thế sao
à À đấy là ra tôi còn thiếu một cái tôi
sẽ sửa lại một tí nữa
tr2 làm mấy ông có thể là
điền cái gì nó sẽ tự động Điền những cái
con lại không ơi
ừ ừ
Ừ cái này cách đặt tên biển mình nha Ê
mấy ông mà ông gõ cái gì nó sẽ tự động
kiểu Điền giống hệt thế
Ừ cái này tớ sẽ nhảy đến
hỗ trợ tâm lý đẹp thời tiết
cho tôi thường thêm một cái khái niệm
after và nằm sau cột vào nhé anh
cho hai thằng ạ
Cho nghe ca nhạc
à à
ở Mỹ ngày thêm được power cái giỏ được
có
một vì khi mà thêm cột mới thường là nên
có một cái giá trị mặc định gì đó không
Nó có thể bị lỗi sẽ defoe nó một cái ở
đây là
Phone này
khi
mở ok
Ừ để power của tôi sẽ là
Phone này thôn bây giờ sẽ đến không thôi
và mình sẽ có thể nằm sau Cột nào đó là
sử đây Tôi ví dụ cứ bắt chước ở trong
cái tôi vừa sửa đây đi vào năm sau cột
xa tất cả lại
là không tìm thấy cái cột này như tôi đã
từng chỉ với ông là mình không muốn để
gợi ý cái này ra chuẩn thì mấy ông sẽ
kết nối đã tao bây giờ đây này nó tụi
bay vào sẽ nó sẽ góp ý ông tên cộp mà
không báo Cường thấy nữa bé với điều
kiện ở mấy ông phải có cả cái lắc in
Word để mà nó sẽ gợi ý câu ashwell cũng
như là nó báo cảnh báo lỗi nếu mà cột
không tồn tại nữa
à à
hay là chạy câu truy vấn ở trong ngày
được nhé Mà nó có hỗ trợ cấp nhưng mà
tôi không dùng cái có sẵn rồi Đâu rồi nó
sẽ gợi ý đây này gợi ý đây nó không báo
lỗi này
À mà cái này của tôi sẽ có xuống dưới
này đó
khi bị Coffee mà
nếu tôi biết các phím
áo phông hoa hết mái nhỉ Chắc không ở
đây tôi chia sẻ đi nhưng mấy ông nữa
quên đấy
lớp trưởng tại hộ tôi lên Combat nhé
chạy Minecraft thôi
có ai sẽ chạy ngay đi petition My Red
thì nó sẽ chạy mỗi cái file thôi Tại sao
nó chỉ chạy 1 file này cho mình xem
đang ở
thì nó sẽ luôn kiểm tra trong cái bảng
myrosin file nào đã chạy và file toàn bộ
file này chạy được một còn đợt 2 sẽ
trình trạng bộ fan này là giữa hai nói
chuyện bánh nếu cậu số tự đợt chạy ngay
để mấy ông hoàn toàn huyện có cái khái
niệm robot là quay trở lại Quay trở lại
bao nhiêu bước 2 quay trở lại đến cái
phần phần nào phần nào để ra hai đấy và
robot thấy bản chất là nó sẽ chạy vào
một cái dốt này nhá nó à Cái đau này nhá
để nó sẽ rồi
Ờ Ờ nó sẽ kiểu quanh một lại mà nên mấy
ông sẽ phải ghi vì ghi vào cái đao để nó
chạy ở chuẩn thì cái đao Nó luôn bị
ngược so với cái thằng áp này những Tôi
từng nói ví dụ à Cái app này của tôi sẽ
là kiểm tra xem mà nếu mà không tồn tại
cái đây không tồn tại cái cột này thì
mình mời thêm cái cột này như thế này
cho
con cái này ngược lại là nếu mà tồn tại
cột này thì rốt và đi Xóa đi đấy cái đấy
mà Giờ bà của tôi sẽ có thêm một là ít
bên Đợt này còn nếu mà ông không thêm
cài Apple này thì mặc định nó sẽ luôn
đầy sống cuối nó sẽ sau cuộc đi thật tôi
không muốn điều đấy
Ừ ok chơi nhạc
nói gì Em tôi hơi sợ rồi không biết gỗ
có người đang nghe hay không ờ
I hear Ờ tôi phải nói lại cái nữa vì có
vài ông vẫn là hơn mông lung nhiều nhất
là mấy ông phải phân công nhau rõ rằng
công việc này và đẩy 7 lên ít nhá mày
Ông nói cho Không cần phải che ở trên
discord có thể chat bằng một cái phương
tiện nào đó có thể là Messenger nhờ tôi
khuyên mày ông có thể trao đổi riêng ở
một cái thường là công việc làm việc
thấy mấy ông nên có hẳn một kênh riêng
không làm kênh chung để mà ngồi chán chị
giả sử ở Messenger rồi Cả đời tôi nó hơi
chát chít một tí có thể Ông nhảy quá đi
Có Hoặc là họ t ram và Smart Vân một cái
kênh riêng truyền để cậu ở trên đấy sẽ
chỉ có nói chuyện công việc em ạ sẽ
không có tin nhắn bị phân tâm bởi người
khác kiểu kiểu như thế Ờ
ở đây và mấy ông phải tạo nét like các
thứ dù nữa Mày không phải thuốc nữa nhau
ở chung nhà luôn chứ chỉ sự kết nối Vân
tránh việc kiểu là có từng vài ông mất
tích đồng đội mấy tuần mới bảo tôi thì
tôi không biết giải quyết về đến nhà
kiểu thế à
a tiếp theo là toàn điện và thuyết trình
công nghệ này à
Ừ cái này một cái ý tưởng Chắc à để cuối
buổi Tôi nói cho mấy ông đi
cái này có các bạn là Nhắc tôi tôi sẽ
nói này sau nhé
Ừ cái này tôi
cái vụ là capesto mày nó còn những cái
ưu điểm mà tôi chỉ biết là cái ưu điểm
đấy thôi Tôi không biết được cái cốt nên
tôi không thể chỉ méo được nhưng mấy ông
sẽ nhận ra được vài cái ưu điểm rõ nhất
là khi mà tôi thường ấy yêu một cái gì
đó nó tiện này mày có Zalo này tôi yêu
một cái gì đó thì nó tự động yêu ở đây
đó Tiện còn không phải cày hết lắp in gì
đó của tôi nó còn gợi ý thêm một vài cái
hiểu ngay mà nên phải có thêm vài cái gì
đó Nhớ ngay đây cái Return trở về hoạt
động tri ân regis tôi sai lỗi chính tả
kiểu ngay ngắn hạn sẽ còn gợi ý thêm một
vài cái chi trả nữa chọn thế Thấy thứ mà
a Và thậm chí nó còn kiểm tra thêm là sử
là ít đôla bằng bằng như này
tất cả nhà sáng ạ thì nó sẽ cậu gợi ý
thêm nào cậu
phải thêm ba dấu bằng hai à đại khái là
đi toilet một cái đây
Ừ thì nó hoàn toàn bảo có thể lít Cái
này tách nó ra nghĩa là mình còn hoàn
toàn mà không cần phải Eo đây mình có
toán hệ Return ở đây xong rồi
nếu mất Giọt Sữa không rơi trường hợp
này thì có thể ghi tên đây nữa Cái này
nghĩ ông chỉ đó nó tối ưu trong việc là
gợi ý thứ tôi thấy ra 2 vs Cốt nó không
có điều này tôi khẳng định cái điều đấy
Xong rồi tôi chưa cốc cả lên mấy bởi vì
chính cái nông nghiệp tôi bảo đồng
nghiệp tôi cũng tốt cũng cố TV cốt Và
đôi khi mắc những cái lỗi chính tả hay
mắc thấy gì đó mà tôi vào cốt của họ nó
cảnh báo đỏ lòm anh ta tôi phải sửa cho
họ tôi khẳng định được và cái ID của tôi
có phải đang gợi ý cách
xe xịn hôn
xịn hôn nên là tôi mới được đề xuất
những
không Đúng rồi Và thậm chí là
thực ra thì
tôi toàn làm đó một mình mà tôi nghĩa là
cải thiện trình độ lên tôi lại nhiều đây
Ừ cái này thì cho để rồi sao nói đi Ừ Ok
hôm nay bắt đầu thì thực ra hôm nay vẫn
chưa xong hoàn toàn cơ sở liệu hôm nay
chưa Tạo hết là ship đô Bây giờ tôi sẽ
sinh rủ tao theodore sau đó đi tôi sẽ
ôm cái một cái vài cảnh Tablet về để mà
kiểu làm giao diện nhà sẽ ôm vai cái ga
tôi đây là đang không hình dung được cả
mình sẽ
mình sẽ lấy cái template à
template nào ở làm bên khách hàng đây
tôi đi đâu đấy à
rồi nè
ờ ờ
nào nhỉ
em
phải có chưa chưa
à à
khi kompany như có rồi
em có mini có rồi
Ừ đợi thì tôi xem thì nhé language này a
Company is only
Ừ
đúng rồi bây giờ là trong quá trình làm
cái đồ ăn á Làm làm ý ông là đồ án đồ án
đồ án tôi ra trong mấy ông hay là làm đồ
án trang web này
tay vào làm rồi à
Ừ cái gì nhỉ language
which này ở đây là à Rồi
I hope
a report
em gà mấy cái mình cái này có khi không
cần tạo đâu không còn tạo ship đời cho
tất cả tất cả các cái đâu
khi bé mình cần làm giao diện đúng không
với tôi sẽ ôm thử một giao diện một
trang nó về đi
[âm nhạc]
vay template điệp khúc thêm một chỗ Phi
làm đầu đã ăn Tết à
vì bally
muốn chat đúng chat
Ừ tôi sẽ dùng có chap 4 bị tối cũng cổ
hổ không biết bốn trăm năm cột như thế
nào nữa sẽ dùng một chap 4 ừ
Anh Chính ơi là miễn phí và m Bolero
ở Châu Phi
amin thì mình dùng cải á
ừ ừ tôi thích thì tội bắt chước dùng hết
cái này cho mày không thích nha Ở nhà
bữa chap 41 chap 41.5 này 100 năm rồi
Vì sao dùng là miễn phí mà làm một cái
là
phẩm
Ừ chắc tâm phẩm không có
thì mình sẽ ôm từ cái bên này
Ê mày có hơi ít mà cho sản phẩm
Cho tôi mua bộ
mua bộ để mà làm cái giao diện đẹp màu
mày rồi nghe tôi nhớ tôi vẫn - đâu rồi
nếu ông hoàn toàn thể có thể súng thể
lấy hack này có thứ này
anh Đang rồi
Em hãy hyper của tôi hyper của anh có
nhưng mà hyper của anh thì
nó không có trang sản phẩm
ừ ừ
Ừ anh mơ thấy bơi anh lại để xử nó đâu
rồi
em nói tiếp đi
sản phẩm Tức là cái trang ta
gọi là Trang nhé Post không phải gõ tên
gì Là cái trang kiểu để bên khách hàng
để xem ấy là bên là ứng cử viên để xem
để Phi tô các thứ ấy
could come back
a cho bị ngáo rồi thì như thằng sau Bây
giờ tôi đang nào không gặp à
a nhớ Quế tiếp và phân biệt là mày Cái
này nó không khác nhau mấy
để hiển thị ra kiểu dạng là sản phẩm đâu
ừ ừ
thế này không có nhậu không có
Ê thằng này helper này của tối hình
không có luôn ý
từ ngày cũ ở hyper hay tôi cũng
à à
Ừ
hình như là vừa rồi tôi bị chặn ram chết
luôn vậy Alo alo nhưng không còn thấy on
không
Ừ vợ tôi có bị tràn lan vì vậy chết luôn
à
ừ ừ
U23 giờ Không không có rồi
mày bị đứng CPU vậy
à à
Ừ vợ thông tí đã đồng ý
chi tiết sản phẩm nó không có trang Xem
tất cả sản phẩm à
mì nữa nha kiểu gì phải có bên admin
trước mà tôi sẽ làm bé amin trước và mấy
ông rồi tôi sẽ tìm lại một cái template
nào đó ở bên khách hàng với là mình
khách hàng chưa sau nhé Không hôm hôm
nay ngồi mò hay tốn thời gian tí Ok Bây
giờ tôi có thằng hyper rồi đúng không
tải hình IV Đây Rồi
Ừ
tôi sẽ ôm cái giao diện về bắt chước hôm
trước tôi từng làm mình ông thôi
chị
sẽ thử làm lại mà không xem này
Ờ Ờ cái này tôi nhớ là
a batico
Ừ nó kiểu ngay bây giờ rồi
nhà đất
ở ngoài Bắc này trông ngầu nhỉ được đẹp
đấy chứ ạ
cái bên trong người đi ạ
khi đôi khi copy về anh anh
ở đây
Ừ rồi
ở đó
ừ ừ
a rare Dynamo
Xóa đi
Ừ
thì ông xã nhà lên khá nhiều
ừ ừ
a tiếp theo nữa không thể bay bay hết
cái này được
nhà mình có làm Inax mà thôi nhưng thích
để lại mình sẽ làm cái nick này đâu Cái
này sẽ nhờ
em xin nghỉ vk mình hai ngôn ngữ rồi
thông báo thông báo cũng để lại cũng
được thế này cái này sẽ gì đó không Cái
này
Ừ cái này
em bỏ này đi này bộ hai cái đấy đi
ở tốp này này đây lại đấy ok sốt về lại
sốt chưa biết suốt cái gì cơ Để lại đi
Sau
đó mình sẽ có lại khác như thế này mình
sẽ edit HTML này copy toàn bộ Cái này nó
chúng ta có trang web của riêng chúng ta
rồi à
khu resort này đây xóa file vô cơ mà đi
nè
Anh ở News
thế này
ở
Masters Airblade chấm PS
á nhon
Ừ nếu xấu nhà chúng ta sẽ làm gì khi
format
đã đỡ hơn là bao đúng không Để tí format
dần dần dần sau ok à
an toàn bộ cái
ở CF này Xóa đi này
Ừ làm đi Điên à mà sao
vì họ bay này
ừ ừ
cài Win rồi nó nhẹ được à
khi em thốt lại thức opti bỏ đi này hoa
viên cần để lại này
A3 đi Cái gì gió nha Mẹ cho con vích để
mà đắp Ok Để nguyên này à
xe Nouvo
a
logo vì sau sau màu thiết kế logo hộ tôi
nhé Tôi kém thì giao diện nếu không
thích cái logo anh em dùng chung Ok cái
này về cơ bản nó là open-source mà anh
em mình dùng chung
ờ ờ có thật hay logo cả à
là mình sẽ copy cái đoạn đoạn này từ
ở Hội Nghĩa tôi cứ nhảy sang bên này á
không đóng đóng ở bên này bị lỗi rồi sao
à à
v-app site ba sẽ vứt sang một cái file
Ê bà size 3
Plus đ.tp
format thôi mà không đều ấy à Tôi sẽ thì
tôi sẽ dùng sau tay Tách cái format lại
mình cứ tạm tạm tạm đề đây á Tôi sẽ ở
bên web này đúng không
I get Ơ này view này
I Lay out
a Master này
gì chấm tét
Ừ vợ giao diện hai rồi cho trả nổi thì
phải CS mình đã có đâu mình sẽ
I can show đây này
anh ấn vào từng cái một cái pha với tần
này là ai cần của logo của cha tạm bỏ để
đề đấy đã đây copy cái này là mean
bố mẹ bây giờ Việt Nam mấy topic này tạo
thư mục sẽ
ở trong này
a tiếp theo
khi cài làm đi này nhìn uốn nhẹ ai cản
ơi
ở lại này đó thôi bên này mình sẽ sửa
lại access cho nó
thì mình sẽ sửa đây là axit
ừ ừ
em copy Dạo này thôi
thứ là cái này tôi không biết đi xe bồ
tôi chưa dùng cái đi xe bồ luôn không
biết cái đó dụng gì à
Ừ cái này ai đi À thì ra chẳng quan
trọng Đấy bỏ đĩa
- bổ Cám chỉ ở không
bỏ Bà Điểm
Em thử nhé Nếu bỏ này đi thì inplus về
tao cũng nghỉ đấy
nha Xóa ID
em xóa đi
anh đi xe bộ hay xóa thử hẳn cái này nhé
không cần
Ừ nhưng mà thôi chú thích ở đã về sau
lỗi Mở lại
mình sẽ có
I Love In Tokyo Black Zin cày papain cho
mát rồi mà Cho biết rồi
à Còn vi format thì nó ở cái khác
em
biết hả Có này
ờ ờ
cần Ai cần mình sẽ
access này copy cả thư mục Phone này
em vợ trong ngày thôi là được
ừ ừ
ăn xong coi cần cái bay đâu nè
anh hơi say nhé
máy bay
bị xóa luôn cả này đỡ phải sửa sẽ à
Ừ Ok bây giờ ngày còn thằng này tiếp
theo
ở Tab Vietcombank ở đây Vietcombank ở
chú ý
anh bình tĩnh bình tĩnh nha ở đây top 3
đây 3step này
à à
xe tải thế
mình sẽ tạo file tối Hương đập nó hết đồ
Nếu mà tên là top 3 được
mọi người thấy đèn led 3 trong top 3
tuổi
mở bài
a Blade FM kết nối vào bên này
hình ảnh
anh bum mất rồi đúng không ạ
ăn canh Trông ghét nhỉ à
Hà Nội dùng nó sẽ giữ đoạn này
Hà Nội dung nó dỡn này
em
Còn mấy phút tơ
ừ ừ
day 3 luôn bye bà để món trình Cái con
thích mình có dùng quay ba đâu mà xóa đi
Xin chào Cái này cần đấy Hai cái này cho
cân thấp và tim này là cái để mà cái
thấp patê để cho một vài trường hợp và
kiểu để mấy ông giống xem mấy cái cẩu nó
lên xuống ngay cái gì đó này nghĩa giờ
trang này cần Thôi không phải áp dụng nó
gọi cha tôi xóa đi để mua áp và đi này
à Bố mày cái này Xóa đi này
anh ạ
anh em mình sẽ chỉ cần cài thêm hai này
thôi này
ở bản đồ này
Ê bà app
à à
cho EX
này là đúng
sau đó Bây giờ mình sẽ in Plus
cô từng tham hàng là
saipa đúng không này
chú ý hay phết
Saipan
nó có này bên này
Xin lỗi anh kiện đi tiếp theo là top 3
này
chịu nghỉ kệ nha à
xe Open a
Không hiểu sao vỡ này thì đó xem lại
contain nó sẽ là nhiều trong ngày đúng
không giống như nói đi đâu
anh không được nghỉ luôn à ta thật
content cho máy
ờ ờ
footer này
ừ ừ
Ừ chị nói
đi lung linh luôn ok chưa à
anh Lung Linh đấy
có hai dạy nghỉ
đi này
chờ đợi tí nha à
Ừ tao lúc tao này làm gì đấy
chị trúc 3da in
giá xít ờ ờ
Mở bản đồ
Anh Nô là hình ngựa chưa lưu được
Ừ đúng rồi nó chưa lưu được mà sao thỉnh
thoảng lưu lại này bị lỗi không hiểu sao
cho
nó về bấm được
anh em bé đi nghỉ Tôi nghĩ là tôi sẽ đẩy
lên theo nào lại ngồi sửa tôi sẽ khó
chịu thế tôi chịu
à à
ờ ờ
người lắm Ok
Ừ thế xong rồi giao diện bên khách Hà
tiếp theo là mình sẽ làm trước để À đúng
rồi mình phải làm cả giao diện cả đăng
nhập nữa vụ từ Vũ Đăng nhập Đấy trang
đăng nhập xong mình làm tính năng đăng
nhập sau đó thì ở midway rồi ạ Mình sẽ
bắt đầu xanh
có e Tôi vừa thấy có lấy sóng rất này
anh ở đây trang này trang kiểu dáng phù
đặt ở bên đó boss thôi chứ không phải
trang này à
Anh ta đã có thấy bồ đấy mẹ không chịu
khó chịu mà đúng không chúng đẹp mà Ờ
thì
thì mình sẽ làm ở bên A
anh ngủ trước là đăng nhập này đăng ký
cũng được các yếu thứ có vài cái giờ hai
đây có cả hiểu trang vô hiệu hóa tài
khoản cơ động cơ Thế bạn đã bị khóa cho
nó thế hoặc là xác thực email rất là 2a
phải copy cái sáng anh
xem nào nữa
thời trang giới thiệu bản thân
Ừ cũng được vì sao ôm trạng này về nhưng
mà lấy lấy ảnh đại diện từ
có mã số kia cũng được mình có Avatar mà
không cho tao đây ạ
Ừ rồi hả Tôi có rồi mà gọi chia sẻ cái
template hyper này ở trên link này rồi
mà
Ừ ông xem lại nha à
Hà
Nội đang ở đây mình sẽ làm cho máy ngập
đi
Ừ dạo này có làm cho máy ngập trên
ở trên ạ
website tôi pin tôi đấy à
ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ không cậu tặng trả về
nhà luôn thôi mình sẽ tạo một cái là our
control
em
tắt này đi đã rồi nếu mở lên rồi mấy ông
bị lỗi chính tả kiểu ngay thì cái chia
mấy ông chạy cái petition nó vẫn sẽ chạy
qua mọi hoài nó sẽ báo lỗi ở đây tôi thử
ví dụ mấy ông nhé Mình cần Zalo này
outventure hội đúng không
à à
300 tính của lỗi này nó sẽ được báo Mua
dụng rồi sao anh thả tính một lỗi
Ừ anh ở nhà
a Google tính các mẫu dụng hay nhỉ Tôi
mới gì đấy à
chị sẽ có đâu Ở đây I Found your money
Ừ lát nữa Bà đây mình sẽ nhảy đến đau
thôi
ừ ừ
gì
Ờ Ờ
nó toàn luôn trả về voi khó chịu nha Đợi
thì tắt cái ở trong nhẹ lai Tablet giá
rẻ
đi tại sao nó lại tự động mở lên nhỉ cái
nha
Có ai biết
à à
anh xóa The Voice đi
mày ông ký thêm à Cái cốp phòng ra anh
ở
lại là ao nhôm in
ca nhạc
Mình sẽ tạo thư mục không ạ thì tạo thư
mục
Dù
sau này rồi tạo file là log in Complex
Ừ
tôi sẽ làm rất là tỉ mỉ cẩn thận cho mấy
ông đó là từ bỏ qua giao diện thôi à Ừ
tôi sẽ làm hiện tôi sẽ làm rất cẩn thận
về cái vụ là à request valdez có thử thứ
giờ à cẩn thận để mấy ông thể cặp hình
dung được làm chuyên nghiệp và sẽ nhà
tôi không nằm hơi hộp tra ngày lo sẽ làm
cho chuyên nghiệp và đặt tên file có thử
cẩn thận để miếu mà toàn để tham khảo
không ạ Và chúng vào đây Em muốn dự án à
Tôi nghĩ là nó sẽ phải kiên đấy
hồn ma đúng không à
không thừa kế thì giao diện cho nào nên
là đề mình sẽ tạo hẳn phải riêng như thế
này ờ
ấn
vào đây cho chỉ nếu một cái Nếu mấy ông
đấy rồi để ý đó là nhất là ở
Ừ cái tên tên của cái trang web phải ông
thường nó bị lặp lại như thế này béo mà
toàn thì sửa cái tên tên trang web mấy
ông nằm ở trong file nv là nó là à áp
này nếu không sửa cái tên ép lên này đấy
khi đóng góp vào dự án đó thì tôi Open
ruột thế này mà tôi đẩy lên cái tháp của
tôi mời ông vào
Linh đi tháp tôi chỉ với ông nhá chị lại
với ông lần nữa nhé
ờ ờ
ở đây ở dự án này đi pause
khi
bé môi giới Việt Nam ấy Đúng không
mấy ông hoàn toàn thể vào đây đầu tiên
là mình không nên quát người theo dõi đã
đấy Xong rồi méo quay pháp nói về để mà
kéo Cốt về để mà làm gì để mấy ông muốn
sửa đâu thì mới ông xưởng Sau đó ông có
mít lên cho ông sẽ ấn nút tạo Fully quét
để mấy ông à
Ừ thì là tôi sẽ tôi và tất cả mọi người
thể xem được những cái Yêu cầu sửa của
mấy ông để mà hoàn toàn thể xác nhận cái
sửa đấy Khi mà tối xác nhận sửa đấy nó
sẽ được đẩy lên cái cốt chính con không
thì nó sẽ không được đẩy lên cái cái rất
là hai thứ nhất là những sửa lại tôi về
anh cần nữa chồng khó chịu quá à đây rồi
Trưa đi
ờ ờ
ở đầu tiên là mấy ông sửa đầu tiên tôi
đã bảo mày không sợ lại Cái app này đây
và béo mà toàn thể lấy lại được cái app
lên đây chứ chắc là không phải lấy lại
thử phải nv mà mình cũng sẽ lấy từ file
config thường là như thế thôi là trong
Lấy không Lấy trực tiếp từ file nv ra
khéo không bao giờ được phép lấy từ nv
mà luôn lấy được cái Compaq này
sẽ thử ví dụ cho mấy ông ấy trường hợp
anh nhé
Nghe thời sự đài Law in soi kèm tên được
gió đây đúng không thì thường là tôi sẽ
làm đã
Ừ
cái này sẽ đôla thay Thù này còn đấy này
sẽ ra HD mày không áp lên mà tôi sẽ đây
ơi mình có một cái con fix này những cái
app này
ở ngay
em không có công nghệ biến áp đúng
anh đợi tôi mực ký
ta đây đúng không
cho nên này mặc định nó sẽ lần này nhà
tuổi sửa lại đây là sửa lại web
nhà môi giới
Ừ nếu mấy ông bị nếu bị trói tay không
ô tô vợ tắt mở cái này chắc tay mềm ấy
ông bị nghe có tiếng này hơi khó chịu đi
Vì Sao Hôm Sao tôi sẽ tìm cách tắt luôn
tiền có sum à
Ừ nếu để ý kĩ là tôi sẽ luôn Tắt cái
Unikey khi mà tôi gõ cốt là cái gì đó và
tôi khi mà gõ sang tiếng Việt tôi lại
tôi lại cậu auto tôi lại tắt cái Unikey
đi đấy để cho tránh bởi vì thường mình
lập Tân biến mọi thứ mệnh đề tiếng Việt
Chúng mình à nhầm để tiếng Anh nữa mình
không ít khi gọi tiếng Việt lắm à
Ừ cái này thì ra là tôi đang nghĩ việc
làm Nếu để áp lên như này thì ra nó
tiếng Việt về sau mình chuyển sang ngôn
ngữ tiếng Anh và Bỉ
em có khi tôi không dùng cho up lên mày
đâu tôi sẽ viết trong local cái gì đó
ừ ừ
ô ồ
a ho cảm béo mình ngồi nghĩ cái tên mỹ
miều tiếng Anh sẵn Vào ngày đi mà mình
sẽ để cho nó luôn đã dụng weTV
pre-root này
Lý Hải Ừ cũng được
a Huy Chương Tử Di couture tất cả kiểu a
tín dụng
Chị Ba cái này sẽ dùng con thích nhá sẽ
nếu sẽ lấy kẹo dạng nha
tên file app này soi gọi đến xong rồi
chấm thì gọi tên nó lên nha nha
anh đẹp trai
AE
Xem đăng nhập cho ngon
Gọi tui Đợi tí Đợi tí nha vợ yêu
xe khách hàng tôi chẳng chơi này
Ừ đúng nhỉ
outbox in Đúng rồi nhỉ
có hai khổ không Bị sửa thay thổ giữ
nguyên này
thế nào rồi
à à
anh đợi tôi tí our control
du
học Australia
a móc in
ừ ừ
thường nó cho mình bị như này có thể có
nhiều vấn đề còn có thể do cách nữa sẽ
là cách Clear
3 cách layer clear
thường mà nó liên quan đến A clear cả
con fix cả router
anh đợi tôi một tí đã đồng tính
ừ ừ
Ừ nếu hệ
anh xóa view Xóa các router Xóa hết
ừ ừ
phải trong trường hợp mai để nó ở trong
đồ như thế này thì sẽ được
ta có
à à
ờ ờ tiếp theo là mình sẽ có
chèn hai cái này có lý do đó nhỉ
thì mình sẽ đúng cái hiện tại chưa thấy
có vấn đề gì cả Có khi chèn hai cái
thằng này nó mới xuống đây tôi thử xem
em copy cái này đã ai cần nè
có ai cần lấy như có rồi
chỉ cần có rồi
ở mấy nhà mình có hết rồi mình sửa lại
đây access thôi chị copy access ở đây
này Đấy sang bên này được
dự án này được
à à em tắt đi à
anh bum nó
em
xấu ấy nhỉ
Hình như có gì đó Sai sai đây à
ừ ừ
anh đúng không Đó là trong nó có cái
thằng sau này mà hiệu ứng à
à À còn logo luôn đằng sau đúng không
cần logo này à
ờ ờ
bỏ vào Logo đi
ở phút to cái gì đó
anh ở đây
Ở đây cái cái mà tôi bảo là mình ngoài
việc mình để cái app nêm ở đây này mình
sẽ lấy luôn ở trong router nữa mình sẽ
copy ra trong router được ở nhà nó
tôi mình sẽ luôn có đúng không
ca sĩ mà Ê
thik router này đấy à
sửa lại thành năm hiện tại thôi
ở thẻ năm 2022 đến thành năm bao nhiêu
đó tôi thường hay chơi trò này nó đết
ngay
ngay sẽ luôn năm vận tải
à à
a copyright
Còn Nhớ Hay cái thằng bằng nhau thì bỏ
đi
về cách sử ít eo ấy
ít nhá
a sheep Dash này E bằng Bang Bang 2022
sẽ chị 2022 thôi còn eo đấy
em ở đâu Tại sao mình làm mất công nha
Đợi thì được tí nha
em có cái này
The men is
em sẽ copy cái này vào đây
à à
ra cho mua mái hơn
nếu mà khác
à Mà sao mày là chuỗi
Ừ ok
Ừ nếu mà cái này khác thì mới hiển thị
ra
Ừ
ok chưa ạ
em trả về chuỗi nhiều và nó luôn cảnh
báo đây mình kệ à
Anh hát lên blog in rồi nè
khi con chỉ trong mấy ông được cái gì
không nhỉ
khi bạn ngồi thế Meta meta-data này mấy
ông về sau mấy ông cũng sẽ cần phải điền
nhé vì sau tôi sẽ chỉ thiếu mỗi cái mấy
ta làm sao để tạm xóa đi nhé
ờ ờ
ừ ừ
tôi điền cái gì đó
một
buổi buổi sau rồi chắc là tôi sẽ hướng
dẫn mày ông về vụ
đăng nhập bằng O O O
cái vụ mà
mình cho chụp tao đi
học có cái Pocket thì màn đăng nhập bằng
cái thằng thứ ba nó sổ like này
ở đây như này và gần chết hàng ngày nó
làm nó có thể đăng nhập bằng rất nhiều
khoản khác dụ là cả tài khoản Google
Happy Glass cái gì đó đây và có cả tôi
nhớ không nhầm có lấy cân sao nó khỏi
cân lại đây cây này nhà ông chỉ cần cài
cái á cài sol la này về rồi cài thêm cái
link này về cái soi cấu hình african đấy
Sau đó thì tức là sao hoàn toàn thể log
in with Rica knockout về sau để còn nhớ
thì mình sẽ có tóc em để mà lấy tóc em
là ai sẽ to kem Đúng kiểu tôi anh sẽ cho
em Facebook đấy có là để mà lấy cái á
lấy cái á
à à ID và
ID lose your name email Vân Vân Vân có
phải cái Lấy được đấy ở đây nó ghi rõ
này đây ID name avatar email đấy lấy
được bốn cái đấy để mà mình sẽ đăng nhập
nhanh cho người dùng Gọi Đăng ký nhanh
những người dùng đương nhiên à Có một
vài trường hợp ở mấy ông vẫn muốn điền
thêm vài thông tin nữa người dùng thật
sự là người dùng ở
công ty nào hay đại khái như này nữa
đúng không ạ thì cái đấy tôi sẽ
mình sẽ nhảy sang cái trang đăng ký
Phiên Bản Khác Anh nhớ nghỉ do nữa sẽ có
một trang là trang Đan kín phổ thông
bình thường
3000 khỏi phim ảnh khác mà ông sẽ nhảy
sang săn khí Nhưng mà tự động điền hộ
cho người dùng những cái cái váy Thái
thông tin được rồi và yêu cầu người dùng
Điền nốt vài cái còn bạn đây là một cách
có một cái khác của nhiều tra Thì đó sẽ
là sử mấy cái thông tin này không phải
thông tin Quan trọng có thể Điền sau khi
mà người dùng ấn mà cập nhật thông tin
mình chỉ thông báo cảnh báo người dùng
cần điền bổ sung nốt loài thông tin là
Nhạn đấy Ôi nhà con xác thực email nhỉ
anh gửi chưa làm bộ xác thực email đúng
không Ờ tôi sẽ chỉ mày ông cả cụ xác
thực email nữa thì thấy mình sẽ tạo một
bạn nữa bảng chỉ đứng sau sự ký mail đến
các bảng for password nữa là code bán
thuốc có chứ nhỉ
em không có reset có đây rồi Đây chính ở
đây phó đây
ở bảng bảng xác thực Email thì rửa Là
Một là bả xác thực ký mèo Hà chỉ cần
thêm một cột lỡ hội một cột a và cột a
email confirm nhưng mà
Ý tôi nói chung là mấy ông thích cái nào
thì cũng kiểu mùa đào tạo phần bạn riêng
chị Liên quan được gửi mail để xác thực
email đấy để chính xác phải biết được
tránh việc là người ta có thể giả Email
gì đó hay là
nên chỉ còn thêm một cột là ít con
Phương lại chẳng hạn thế để kiểm tra xem
email chuẩn lại không à
khi
con gì nhỉ
à Sao bây giờ có ông nào mới bắt đầu vào
này ờ
diện nữa nhé
à à
thêm về giao diện gì về nữa
lộ diện là tương đối rồi
từ hôm nọ hôm nay mà dạy thêm cái gì gì
đó nữa thì nó lại hơi quá tải quá Chúng
tôi đang thử nghĩ xem nó dậy thêm được
một cái Dinh nho nhỏ nữa ừ
đăng kí ở mình làm luôn chưa đăng ký nhỉ
có tiền sao đăng nhập thì mình sẽ về có
bạn thì nó sẽ như thế này điện một vài
cái gì đó Ở đây
Em hãy cho mùa Mẹ Út thôi
ừ ừ
anh bấm để xem
Ừ nó cho làm tính năng này lừa
Ừ thế kỷ Có thể tôi đã chỉ luôn ông cả
vụ này thì tôi sẽ nốt lại cho mấy ông
chú mèo muốn gì cũng chiều cả vụ bấm đề
để hiển thị ra password cũng được xe thì
ra mẹo nhau khi chỉ luôn nhé chị luôn
cho nóng hổi nhé
cho nó biết là cái trò này không Nó biết
rồi cho Bấm vào cái này thì mà nói thì
dễ password không
anh em cho chị rồi nhé à
khi dùng gas thận nhé hay là dress with
a2dp về cơ bản nó sẽ gõ gõ nhanh hơn
hoặc làm thật được
à à
Ừ thế là
tôi sẽ bắt cái trạng thái Angeles ở đây
đi So sánh nhảy đến cái Hà
live show password ông ạ
mà ở
Số Phận
a comment
Xin chào ma
I let her
ừ ừ
Ừ thôi vẫn thích dùng cái series cho
Tùng mình còn dễ hiểu hơn ông đỡ phải
nhờ thế này Đợi tí nhá như là thằng
em à Nhìn thằng này À đúng rồi tôi chưa
trình Cái access của nó bảo sao Có khi
là nó có sẵn rồi ông ạ đợi thì như có
sẵn rồi
nữa
Anh đang
ai
ngờ rồi tôi cứ chỉnh cho mấy ông này mới
ông xem được à
ở nhà tôi vẫn muốn ôm XIII về máy để làm
đoạn này nó nhanh lười thì làm cái này
bằng ra ship thận á Cái gì đâu nhé
ở bên trên w e
Ừ ok
mình đây sẽ là
a password này
à à
ừ ừ
tính thai mà nó gì Bá Tánh
xin lỗi
anh em nhé
à à
em đã xem à
về chưa
à Đây
là hình cái đây phải xóa Ali vậy
anh sex lót lại đây đã con solo
slot 1 đấy xem có nhảy điều đây mà
à à
Anh ấy đưa vào nha
A One Click here click nhỉ
anh sai tại vậy
ở
nick kia chưa Mình nhớ nhầm sang ở đâu
đấy bộ máy này anh không được này mình
sẽ phải thêm cái giàu đây này
à à
Anh nhớ để trọng trường hợp mà bấm vào
đấy hiển thị ra như thế này
ông ngoại nhưng mà cái này phải biến
thành cái á
Ừ tôi sẽ để đây tôi thường hay cho nó 1
cái data đây thay vì kiểm tra rồi Kiểu
gì đó sẽ cho nó 1 cái data đây ví dụ
data đây là
cả hai lần nhà hả
anh bằng xu hạn bằng 1 đi cũng được
cái điểm gì mình sẽ kiểm tra trước người
ta sẽ ít
lại không sử dụng nó giết được giống nhà
dùng còn đầu Ji trong trường hợp anh
chuyển qua đây
Có ai đi đây đi được đi bước Tân What
would i
Mỹ Tâm bắt cóc này
xe máy cày data của nó và hai đình
khi Băng Băng
Ý
là mình sẽ ghi lại tại data cho ngày
Lê Hoàng không đồng thời mình sẽ đổi
luôn cả cái
a-class cho nó
ai đây ai bây giờ gì nhỉ
Ừ Đợi thì đợi đi
à à
ở đó là
anh nói before cái gì đây
Ai biểu tượng này biểu tượng gì vậy
tượng đấy ạ
anh đi thêm class nó alo
Ừ chắc trêu
ai biết được đi biểu tượng này còn gì
đấy
Ừ ông
ở
lại chơi mẹ mày
Anh xóa đi này
có gì
chi tiết
có ai ai
em ngồi mất mười mấy phút nữa ngồi đọc
lên mắt à
before-after à
em bị chồng gas này nó chẳng có nhớ cái
thằng ai này
a small được
a high-tech
a and classes
à à
Ừ lát này sẽ làm gì đó
các clip này nó sẽ có
à à
bấm vào là theo cái đít này
Xã hội phức tạp quá Áp dụng cái này nhé
tôi tôi chỉ có ý thế thôi tạm mộ qua con
mắt đi
một này
Ê mày cái kia mày ông mà không thấy Cốt
nó thôi gợi ý cho mấy ông Xem cốt nó đây
à
Anh ơi bấm bấm ăn Ok tạm chấp nhận cái
mắt mà mua dụng đi
dọa tôi vừa chỉ mấy ông cách lấy cốc nó
rồi luôn sẽ Tôi ôm Cốt nó về thì mày Ông
lại bảo tôi lựa lòe ạ đó Có cốc luôn kìa
đây nhưng đại khái cách làm nó sẽ đơn
giản như này thường là nó sẽ thay đổi
cái nó là cái ai cần nó thay đổi cả Ai
cần chứ mày thêm class như thế đâu thì
tôi đã thấy nó hơi sai đấy Không Ai Làm
Thế đây cả
Em hãy làm điều đấy à
qua được cho mấy ông vài cái mẹo không ạ
mày Ông thấy được cái mẹo đầu tiên à từ
việc màu trong
cf của nó mỏi trong fage Swift của nó
lấy cốt này vào ban đại khái như thế à
Ừ Ừ chẳng hóa áp dụng thế cả Tôi đã từng
làm cái này rồi hào làm kiểu thế cả đấy
nhưng mà
ở buổi hôm sau thì À nói cho mấy ông có
đề xuất gì mày ông thắc mắc cái gì mấy
ông cũng có thể hỏi nữa để buổi hôm sau
tôi sẽ vừa là không ạ Bữa sau tôi sẽ cố
làm thì nó đăng ký và kèm theo cả cái
thư viện này nếu thế tôi sẽ phải tôi có
thể hôm đấy tôi cũng sẽ tự
ngồi làm luôn luôn mới ông xem trực tiếp
luôn đó tôi sẽ ngồi đăng ký cái app link
này để cho mày không biết được hình dung
được nhưng mà đăng ký một cái app để nó
xin quyền và như thế nào chúng tôi không
chắc được là có thể cấp độc quyền ngay
đâu nhiều về áp nhiều trang nhiều cái
mạng xã hội khi mình đăng ký áp xong
mình có thể test được luôn có nhiều cái
ạ nhiều tranh thì nó phải kiểu phải đợi
suy cơ
nó hơi làm nhanh tí đấy
ờ ờ
đầy đủ tính năng về cái out đấy con Bộ
hôm nay tôi định làm không ai ra tôi tôi
cũng nghĩ là chỉ làm đo diện và các nóng
của cái không thể tiêu đề có mỗi em giao
diện thôi cũng chỉ định làm thế thôi
ờ ờ
mã OTP ê
anh có nhớ không lầm lả mất tiền đấy
tính sau A
tôi Tôi không nhớ về cả ra Speed phần
lắm Tôi không biết cứ làm đi cẩu này cho
mấy ông dây dung ấy sửa lại chị bưu của
nó nghe được
anh tâm sự thì cũng để buổi sau nhé Có
nhiều câu hỏi mà từ buổi trước tôi còn
chưa tổng hợp lại để mà mấy buổi trước
nữa tôi còn chưa tổng hợp lại trả lời để
buổi sau tôi sẽ tổng hợp nốt
em ăn gì nhé Chúc anh em vẫn thường nốt
mấy tiếng còn lại trước khi ngày mai gì
đây like Tôi cũng đang bị đến like gì
đấy
Xin chào miệng em nhé cốc này tôi sẽ đẩy
lên ý
em sợ nhiều phết nhỉ Cái gì Idol
cái cảnh báo đó là không nên đẩy cái thư
mục add đôi khi nó sẽ có một cái vài cái
gì đó nguy hiểm cho mày nghe ạ tôi sẽ
chỉ với ông về đã thích lo ngày nay ít
nó không phải cái này Mày lo cái toàn bộ
đấy trong thư mục hay đi thì sẽ ra Ừ nó
bỏ qua bỏ qua khi để ý đấy sửa lại trong
cái lít NO
ở ngã bỏ qua toàn bộ thư mục này
em
chào Thầy em mới vô à thôi đi đi
anh có thể ghi lên ôm BS cái thời gian
bắt đầu like cho đến khi đóng nay được
không
khi
cha luôn
ờ ờ
khi sex
ô mai bà cốt
Ừ ok
Nghe ca cổ
a lifetime
mà làm lại
mở bài thân Swift their time
em chuyển những cái này
hình như là thời gian thôi cả
à à
nữa hay là bắt đầu Like là lúc nào
a bắt bắt đầu nan Anh nghĩa là mình sẽ
lưu lại lúc bắt đầu like còn Lai bao
nhiêu phút thì em có thể xem xem à
chị xem ngay trên YouTube có mà Thế mà
bảo này bao lâu mà đúng
người đang xem được một tiếng 50 phút
ở sâu Hà mà
em còn bình tham
à Thế à mình có thể cài thêm ứng dụng
thứ ba ở đây mày hiển thị ra
chị đã bắt đầu like nào
I Swear downtime điều kiện thế nhớ lúc
ấy tôi phải luôn nhớ bấm bấm cái đấy
cho xem
chị Thu
ừ ừ
Anh sex Ê mày áp dụng lắm cái thứ đi
anh gọi lắm hiệu ứng đau mắt luôn
bộ phim sex Esports
ê ê
anh nói
những động thái bình quân trên thị
trường dầu
ê ê
em ngủ ngon
Ừ nếu
ờ ờ
I know I know dear
a
website that will interact
bộ phim sex
đi làm
tách này
ở Cydia
ờ ờ
địa chỉ
a
full screen
khi sex
phim hài
I stop What are
ô tô quá ngon
ừ ừ
Ừ tao được
Ừ mẹ đây đúng không
see More
anh xóa
anh em
Ê mày làm hiệu ứng quá nghe quá
A và sói
I Swear đang nghĩa là tôi sẽ không nhớ
lại mà bấm cái oto kia
có ai phải ô tô nó mới chuẩn hơn
à à
này nó chuẩn hơn đúng không Chứ không
phải là
bộ phim sex gái ngồi vào đấy Ở Chọn theo
tu kiểu này đã nó hơi mất thời gian mà
không nhớ không tiện chích Attack
hình ảnh
em có hỏi chấm Không bấm được vào cái
nhà
ừ ừ
ở Los this special
nghĩ là tra phải
ý nghĩa
Ừ để bữa sau đi để bữa sau thử thử xem
nó tự động nhé
Anh
về rồi
Ừ
ok nha à
Ừ thôi chào bạn nhé Mỗi mai hai tiếng
thôi